اه اه
ثقافه تشجيع هذه مثل الهرمون الواحد مدمن
على هذا التشجيع احساس حب جميع الشعوب
[موسيقى]
انني رحال من اجل الكره واحنا مجانين
الكره اول ذهابي باللباس تقليدي كان في
البرازيل فقلت انا البس تقليدي بس مبين
للناس يعني ثقافتنا العربيه
[موسيقى]
المنتخب الجزائر
بدل اهتمام بكره القدم يعني احنا صغار
نسمح للفريق الوطني
احب المنتخب الجزائري وحب العرب في
المونديال
[موسيقى]
اول مره
كان في مونديال جنوب افريقيا وكان اننا
سافرنا يعني بس نحضر المونديال هناك
وتعرضنا يعني لمسافه طويله وكان حظنا اننا
نشارك
تاشير الدخول الى زلمه
[موسيقى]
اول ما ذهابي باللي بس تقليدي كان في
البرازيل فقلت انا البس لبس تقليدي بس
مبين الناس يعني ثقافتنا العربيه وكان رب
فعلا انا كنت انتظر رد فعل لك الرعب سعر
الروعه انهم كل حاول يتصوروا معايا واخذوا
معايا ذكريات روعه وخاصه البرازيليين يعني
البرازيليين الارجنتينيين الامريكان
كل الاجناس
[موسيقى]
هذا اللباس يمثل مناطق الصحراويه يعني من
شمال الى جنوب المغرب العربي ولباس
اجدادنا من وقت الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كبير في العالم
[موسيقى]
انك تكون سفير المشجعين مثل الهرمون يولي
الواحد مدمن على هذا الترجيع انا
الجزائريين اصلا مجانين كوره
كاس العالم
نحن ماشي موجوده الجزائر بس احنا الجزائر
على جنب هذا كاس العالم كاس العرب المنتخب
[موسيقى]
سعد الجزائري اللي انا مبني القاهره